e
e e
good morning um I'm going to call the
house Judiciary Committee uh to order
and um before we begin would you please
uh stand and join me in pleasure
allegiance alance to the flag United
States of America the stands
Na
indiv and justice for
all all right so um we have uh three
bills that we um that were voted for
interim study that we now need to uh
make a decision on as to whether or not
um we recommend that it's uh that this
that the subjects of the bill should be
um recommended for further legislation
legislative action in the upcoming
session or not um the first one is House
Bill 1089 and so I would open the our
executive session on that bill that
deals with
um uh eliminating the statute of
limitations uh on uh civil actions
involving uh p uh contamination and does
anyone um wish to speak representa here
if you would like to hear from her um
sure yes um if you'd like to
representative if you'd like to come up
thank you Mr chair um thank you ranking
member Smith um I just have a few brief
remarks to let the committee know um
that the bill is refiled at this time
and I'm working to see if there is a new
way to determine the length of time
explicitly in law that someone would
have to seek remedy for a p pasas injury
um without making an indefinite statute
as the bill is written right
now and I'm actually not sure that as
the bill is written right now it would
remove any statute of limitations and
make that so that people actually have
more time I think it might just repeal
what was put in law with House Bill
regardless I truly believe and I know
because there is a lot of backing behind
the bill although you see just me that
an entity would need more time than 6
years to um disentangle the very complex
situation of liability for the damages
to water supplies and to
individuals in marac and there is a
consent decree that's involved where
some of the issues were taken care of um
probably more in a Band-Aid type of way
which I don't like to say in this formal
setting um but I just wanted to give
those remarks over to the committee and
let the committee know that I've
discovered that this is a lot more
complex and that um we need a lot more
input to take it further so thank you
for listening to my remarks all right
questions for this one yes
representative M thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
representative Val what statute of
limitations are you thinking of in your
new bill
well
my what I need to do is sit down and
work this out with OSS to some extent
because I told them that if we're not
able to um write the law in a way that
gives an indefinite amount of time
for a entity or a person to bring suit
that um that may not
be at all feasible either but is there a
way that we can
determine an appropriate length of
time and in the example of you know a
person finding out that they are having
cancer and then they develop another
cancer after they settle so from three
years we went to six years but by doing
that we added a statute into a statute
of limitations we prescribe the number
and we put it in and to take it out
would just revert it back to three years
as far as I can tell so this is why I'm
saying it's really complex but I would
like to arrive at a 10year or some what
does it take I mean a water supply a
city water supply discovers that they
have to mitigate how long is it going to
take before they know extent of what's
going on there when you look you just
find more and more and that's the thing
about pasas so we do want to hold people
accountable and this is a number one of
an accountability slate of bills that
we're bringing forward and we're
extremely open to any feedback that will
make good statute that doesn't need to
be tested in the
court right other questions for for this
witness seeing none uh thank you very
much thank you is there anyone else here
that um wishes to uh say anything about
uh House built
1089 all right uh so representative trip
do you have uh I'll make a motion okay I
move uh inexpedient to legislate House
Bill 1089 well well you know no I think
the as I understand it there are three
three things we can do oh we can uh we
can make a we can have a motion for not
um that we should that we recommend that
the house not take any further action on
this subject number one number two that
we recommend that the house do take some
further action on this subject or if we
were split equally then it would be no
recommendation um so in light of that
representative trip do you have another
I I I I move that the house take no uh
further action on this bill all right
and do you wish to speak to that sure uh
the the the first reason I had for not
uh wanting to take any uh further action
was that uh and an open time limit is a
little excessive you know uh
uh as a as a cancer survivor I know that
uh U it takes a while for people to uh
uh determine and that the that you do
have cancer and possibly what its cause
was uh uh the representative's uh uh
testimony on uh that uh she's submitting
another bill you know uh which has you
know uh improvements you know makes uh
the reason for not taking any action on
this bill even more uh logical all right
all representative Smith and then
representative
Manos thank you Mr chairman um uh I I
agree with what representative trip has
said but I come to a different conclus
clusion it is very definitely because
the sponsor of this bill and others who
support its concept believe that there
is a legitimate issue here that is
important we've seen
indications um of the fact
that that sometimes the principles
involved um uh do not in a timely way
indicate
responsibility and while we recognize
that the bill as it's written um does
not come up to the standard we would
like I think it makes very clear that we
should
recommend this bill for further
consideration by the house and knowing
that what since this bill is now dead um
that that what the prime sponsor and her
allies will be doing is coming in with
an improved version of a bill that
addresses a problem that we acknowledge
did I make that too complicated but I
would hope then that we would recommend
this issue for further consideration
thank you representative
Manos Mr chair I just wanted
clarification over whether um
recommending further action means in the
general ener subject area of pasas and
statute of limitations or whether it's a
decision on this particular bill that I
mean I
think I think you raise you hit the nail
right on the head because I I I think I
agree with both what representative trip
said and with what representative Smith
said and it turns on the very issue that
you raised
I personally I feel very strong
that I could not I don't think I could
ever support eliminating the statute of
limitations completely for P or really
for I I can't frankly it' be hard for me
to imagine ever eliminating the statute
limitations for you know other other
than maybe murder which it already
doesn't apply but other than that it's
hard for me to imagine why you would
ever eliminate the statu limitations and
so if we view it narrowly you know are
we recommending further legislation on
eliminating the statute limitations I
would have no problem in saying we
should not in agreeing with
representative trip on the other hand I
think representative Smith's point about
you know is there it
it should we say that like you know with
what the legislature has already done
with regard to past we don't have
anything further to do I would tend to
say no we may very well have further
things we need to do
so in that sense I agree with
representative Smith
um and I guess so I let me ask let me
just offer this as one Poss and then I
want to hear from you also represent
Smith and anyone else if we I could live
with saying something
like we we do not
recommend further legislation proposing
to eliminate the statute of limitations
but we do believe that there is a need
for further work in the area of
addressing pasas and you know perhaps
there needs to be some adjustment in the
statute of limitations with regard I
could live with
that represent thank you um uh
representative um in in response to your
question these bills are now dead that
that's it we are not not going to vote
on the bills again um and so anything
that happens must come into the
legislature in a new bill and what the
sponsor has just explained in a way that
I found quite informative and I hope
other people do too that she had she she
recognizes two things first there is a a
serious problem three serious problem
inv related to
fast second there is a need to make sure
that we have the ability to pursue
situations in
which people had not acted
appropriately and three how we do that
needs to be rethought and
reconsidered and so recognizing all
those three things I think all we have
to do is say yes we recommend
further action we're not saying this
bill because this bill is now
dead thank you representative hon well
just put simply further action already
is being taken so I would uh I've been
inclined to vote to recommend further
action because I think I I think her
efforts will result in something that'll
be very useful and um hopefully we'll be
able to pass something next session so
other
comments yes represent
St I like the uh principle of the bill
and this is an important issue and we
need to have something to address the
the
uh the results of P injuries um but I'm
troubled by two things the indeterminant
uh period of
Discovery and um maybe there should be
some sort of evidentiary proof of harm
linked to the
pasas um I I think it's the bill is a
good start but it it needs some
important points added to it and so I
would be against uh a non-
reccommendation and I would be in favor
of recommending uh for further
legislative
action so let me let me ask let me just
any first of all anyone else want to
comment any other comments so let me ask
you rep I'm sorry representative trip go
ahead uh this is a a learning action for
me today uh so if we were to recommend
no further action would that prohibit uh
filing of a bill no not at all not at
all and if we were to uh uh recommend uh
further
action would that limit the the scope of
what the new bill would say no I think
you know I I mean I'm I I may if
somebody has a different view I I think
largely what we're doing here today has
very little in terms of actual
consequences that was my third question
the only thing that I suppose it might
have is if there turned out to be a
controversy down the road next session
with some new
legislation somebody might be able to
argue well you know this committee this
committee did recommend further
legislation on the one or this committee
didn't recommend further legislation on
the other hand my sense is that you know
that and uh probably $5 will buy you a
cup of coffee nowadays um but uh other
than that it it probably has not much uh
effect thank
you um so here's here's let me let me
make a suggestion and see if we and just
before we take a vote just ask for a
show of hands what if we were to say we
do not um without in any
way endorsing or not endorsing the idea
of eliminating a statute of
limitations um we agree uh we recommend
that further action on the issue of um
uh uh the problem of past contamination
uh be considered by the legislature when
every can I ask if I so if I and I'll
I'll write that down to to uh make sure
I've worded it correctly um but and then
I'm going to ask for just a show of
hands can I ask one clarifying question
of course is it would we say related to
statute of limitation specifically that
further act consideration is necessary
or just in PS in general because that
seems very broad I I guess I would say p
in general which I mean wouldn't that
wouldn't certainly wouldn't preclude
considering statute limitations because
I think they're probably is you know I I
think we my suspicion is we're not done
with uh the whole P issue and not not
only dealing with statute limitations
but other
things um all right
going
so what so what if
uh this would be my motion I I and I
just ask for a show of hands vote first
um that that our committee say that
without endorsing or not
endorsing uh the elimination of the
statute of
limitations um this committee agrees
that further legislation regarding P
contamination should be considered by
the
legislature can I ask for show of hands
of people that would support that as a
as our recommendation
pardon representative are you you oh all
right Representative testerman no all
right so if I got am I have I got
everyone except for representative
testerman and representative Andrews
were you in agreement you were okay just
a
point ah okay ah that's right so there
was I you had a motion was there a
second for representative trips motion
I not to not recommend but you if you're
at li no that that legislature take no
further no further action if you want to
I didn't I don't think there was a
second for that and if you want to rec
if you want to withdraw that motion that
would be
fine n oh I'm sorry there is a second
okay there is a second all right um so
do you and you stand by the motion well
as as I understand and no further
action uh I stand by it okay all right
all right any further discussion on on
the motion to uh take no further
action all right then um I'm sorry
yes can you use your
microphone add f
oh oh
sure agree that Future Okay that future
legislation regarding PE sure yeah
that's fine I think I said further but
future is fine meanwhile we we better
just deal with representative Trip's Mo
represent chp's motion so so the motion
uh before the before us now is to take
no further action on this area at all
and so that's um I think we're anybody
have any anybody else wish to speak on
that motion all right then I guess we
take don't have a no we don't um so um
you know I uh would you oh yeah done
this
okay yeah sure so it's some
right that's not how it's f
so we
got for
uh uh representative
G has
resigned
sh maybe you know what yeah he's not on
the list because he resigned maybe
that's he's so he's not I mean he's not
a member there but
he really shouldn't have been replaced
okay I but
um all right you know what is is right
right all right so um when you're
whenever you're
ready
so so this is you even need Dolan and
what does that do well I'd put him down
just just yeah
okay everybody else is accounted for all
right so this is the motion this is the
motion to take no further action on uh
on
1089 okay and vice chairman Wallace yay
representative Khan yes representative
Andress yes representative
testerman you know what I'm I'm I have a
feeling that people may be confused
about I think we're right the question
is to not recommend further
action is that AA thank
you uh representative Stapleton
no representative trip
no
okay so hey oh no I'm sorry this is
Dolan start start can we can I can the
the question is to not recommend further
action representative trip I I I will I
will vote Yes then I I pull my know and
and I think we may need to start over so
let me let
me we've all had it's been I think I
hope everybody had a really nice summer
and we all have to kind of get back into
the into the mode here so as I
understand it the motion that we're
voting on now is representative Trip's
motion that we take no further action
which I thought from a show of hands the
people that supported taking no further
action were representative trip and
representative test um and I had at
least the sense from the hand show of
hands that everyone else thought we was
comfortable with the alternative that I
proposed and which if this motion fails
I would offer as the next motion um so
with that in mind can we we uh call call
the role again Vice chair Wallace Stills
vote still votes yay representative Khan
yes representative Andress
representative
testman representative Stapleton no
Dolan representative Boyd
yes representative trip I vote Yes y
representative Dolan
representative Boyd yes representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative D Lorenzo no
representative
Kenny not voting representative
Paige representative Divine no
Representative lonza no representative
Manos no representative tur no
representative Ming no okay
and what about what about me and and
chairman Lynn
no good motion fails all right
so vote
count six to
12 it was six six in favor 12
osed so
unless anybody has an alternative motion
um I would I would
move um that
we um as I said before without uh
endorsing or not endorsing the
elimination of the statute of
limitations we agree that future uh
legislation regarding past contamination
should be considered by the legislature
so that's my motion to ask have a second
a second second by representative Smith
um any further
discussion all right then I would um ask
the clerk to uh call the
role okay Vice chair Wallace
yay oh standby we've got to transfer all
the uh Subs
okay sorry for the delay folks
representative Khan yes representative
Andress representative
testman representative Stapleton yes
representative trip yes representative
Dolan yes representative Boyd yes
representative Smith yes representative
Horgan yes representative D Lorenzo yes
representative
Kenny not here not here representative
Paige not
voting representative Divine yes
representative lonza yes representative
Manos yes representative turer yes
representative Ming yes and last but not
least chairman Lynn
yes okay so we've got look like 19 to
one
16 16 to one yeah okay
16 all right
um oh yes representative
Tre since the motion we just passed is a
a fairly n non-standard motion uh will
we be given a written copy of that oh
absolutely yes you no I'm going to file
I will file a report and I'll be happy
to circulate it to everyone okay thank
you very much no for sure
actually I second the motion is one of
three things it's either recommend for
further consideration or not recommend
for further consideration or no
recommendation that's the motion what uh
chairman Lynn read was in effect the um
I was going to say blur I I really
apologize that the
report that's what he read the
motion is clear we have three motions
that's our choice it's just like we have
a motion generally you know to you know
ought to pass ought to pass with
Amendment itl interim study the motion
in this case is recommend further action
and then the explanation is the kind of
action we're
recommending and no I I agree with that
I spoke to I spoke to uh Paul Smith just
before we started and and that's you
know he said you can you don't have to
put in anything further if you don't
want to but you can and so I would you
know that's why I phrased the motion the
way I did yeah I I would agree that you
should probably put more in since that's
what we voted on right right thank
you all right so I'm going to close the
hearing then on uh HP 1089 and open the
hearing on House Bill
16002 um and is there anyone here who
um wishes to address that
bill seeing none uh do we have any only
sponsor on this a representative
Alexander I think do we have um any any
discussion anyone have anything they
want to say
on
um again I you know I was I sort of feel
that we that we are in somewhat the same
position
um if we look narrowly at whether s we
there should be some further action on
16002 my inclination would be to say no
on the other hand um if if we talk more
broadly about you know to the extent
that this is a an
uh a an issue dealing with housing and
problems
reflecting the housing situation then I
would tend to say yeah there is
definitely a need for further action in
in that area um so represent
Smith um thank you as usual Mr chair I
agree with you completely that we need
to be taking action in the area of
housing um in a lot of ways planning
zoning I hate to use the word but
financing lots of things like that I
think in terms of this particular bill I
would suggest that the
committee recommend no further action on
this particular bill that's not saying
that there shouldn't be further action
in Myriad ways as related to housing but
that this bill does not get us closer to
the goals that we all
share thank you any other other
comments um yes representative
trip I would agree with uh
representative Smith uh when
we make it when we write a report I
would I would assume that
uh we repeat what representative Smith
said that yes there is a need for
something to be done about housing but
uh the solution proposed by this bill is
not uh recommended by the uh the
committee I I like the way you phrase
that and that's maybe what it even a
blind squirrel gets in once in a while
thank
you
Bill um
all right not
um so representative Smith do we have a
do you have a motion
uh light of along the lines of what you
said uh I I would move as to uh House
Bill
1602 that we do not
recommend further action on this bill
all right is there a
second second by representative D
Lorenzo any further uh
discussion representative
St
um without being able to really dive
into the notes that I made there seem to
be a question
of capability uh if you uh
allow greater power to the appeals board
and does that create a backlog with any
number of issues because of a lack of
expertise and certain
areas um that's just by cursory
superficial review of my notes and so um
I would I would agree with the uh non
recommendation any other comments I
guess I I would have to say I mean to
some in a very general sense this this
the this bill is related to the bill
we're going to discuss next dealing with
environmental but I I agree with uh with
representative Smith um
because um the simply giving as as you
pointed out representative St simply
giving as this bill would propose to
give the housing appeals board authority
to review decisions of state agencies
having to do with housing um I I just
don't I don't see that as really a in
any way a uh you know advancing the ball
uh on the whole overall housing issue
and I think we saw at the hearing um uh
we we began to see some of the problems
with it the the uh the Human Rights
Commission said well wait a minute you
can't you know you can't put us in that
um the uh we heard I think evidence uh
about or at least argument about uh the
housing appeals board really has no
expertise in the environmental area they
may have no particular expertise in the
area of highways to the extent that that
impacts um uh housing decisions and so I
I think that
um I have no doubt of the of the you
know the
uh the the good intentions that the bill
was was offered by I tend to think that
it just not um it it's not it's not
something that we want to pursue further
in legislation in that area although we
OB obviously will be dealing with the
housing matter further um so um any any
further comments by anyone on this all
right then I'd ask uh the motion is to
we recommend no further action and I'd
ask the uh clerk to call the role please
Vice chair Wallace votes yes uh
representative Khan yes representative
Andress yes representative testerman yes
representative Stapleton yes
representative trip yes representative
Dolan yes representative Boyd yes
representative Smith yes representative
Horgan yes representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Kenny is not voting
representative Paige not voting
representative Divine yes representative
lonza yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Ming yes and chairman Lynn yes okay
that's 17 to
zero okay
all right
um so that takes care of uh 16002 the
last bill that uh we have to address is
House Bill 16 uh
um which uh relative to judicial review
of Department of Environmental Services
decisions
um and um believe the prime sponsor is
here you please if you'd come up and be
happy to hear from
you thank you very much cherine and
members of the committee for the record
uh representative Rebecca McWilliams
from conquer um you may recall uh we had
a robust discussion at our initial
hearing about this bill talking about uh
Dees and the four uh councils uh and
their roles um in reviewing decisions
um and really I just want to get to the
Crux of this bill because I think it's
important that everyone understand the
goal of this bill is the ability to
appeal decisions of either Dees or a
council that has ratified a decision by
Dees this is not about fixing or
adjusting the way that we have councils
set up right now in the state and I
understand that that is a separate issue
and may be taken up separately uh but
really the goal here is to have the
ability to say the nameless faceless
bureaucracy made a decision and I am not
able to appeal that on scientific
grounds and that is unjust so
fundamentally that was the goal of this
bill um I do want to just note that
there was an amendment to this bill that
I think made it a lot better um so uh to
the extent that there is interest
especially bipartisan interest in
bringing this forward again next year uh
the amendment just for the record is
0869 um and it was a bipartisan
Amendment uh sponsored by man Kenny and
Alexander uh so I think that there there
is opportunity here for justice uh in
terms of creating a appeal opportunity
for when something is decided and it is
unjustly decided and there really is no
way to go back and revisit that decision
right now with our current system um and
just I I do want to reiterate because
it's been a while since that initial
hearing 35 other states besides New
Hampshire have considered and agreed
that there should be some kind of an
appeal so we are a bit of an outlier as
one of the uh 15 states who does not
allow some kind of a justice-based
appeal for discovering new information
and again a lot of our discussion was
about pfas and what that means for human
health and discovering this after the
information has come out after the
decision by a council um so again I
think that this is an update it's
modernization I think it makes sense for
us to consider this and I do think that
um there are some members here who may
be interested in bringing forth future
legislation and I'm glad to discuss
further or answer questions on this
thank you so much questions for yes
representative
Smith now I don't have a question
because I do believe I enthusiastically
support everything that the prime
sponsor has just said um I think it is
not good government that within one
agency there are
Myriad
procedures um and if you happen to go in
door a you have one procedure but door B
another um it is impossible for a
concerned citizen uh to understand what
the process is and know what their
rights are and I think it is essential
that we um pursue this in uh in the
future and would take advantage of uh
amendments that have been suggested new
information but that if we could figure
out um an intelligent responsible way to
handle Appeals
we would be making an enormous step
forward and what well the next thing I
want to say might not be appropriate I'm
still going to say it we have had the
privilege of working with representative
MC Williams over a number of years she
brings to the
legislature uh both design architectural
and legal expertise that is a rare
combination and Incredibly valuable and
I would like to say that I for one am
going to sorely miss her presence in the
future thank
you well I I would make a motion that um
this uh deserves further uh uh
consideration I'll
second Mo motion is made seconded um any
anyone anyone have any other uh
questions for this witness again I want
to Echo representative Smith's uh
comments I'm we're sorry that we I
haven't worked with you extensively but
I would appreciate the input you've
given to this committee and I wish you
the very best in all your future
endeavors thank you both very much it's
been my
honor is there anyone else uh that
wishes to be heard on um House Bill 1614
I'm stap yeah I represent stap
yes um trying to come back up to speed
after a nice summer back in March 6 uh
motion was made for interim study by uh
representative Manos and second by
Alexander um saying a number of agencies
affected and should be involved in work
sessions um I get plenty of time this
representative ly said well it's good
bill but makes another level of review
and work and time
involved what was the outcome of the
work sessions any particular notable
recommendations
or detractions to the bill I I
just I don't really think that there I I
I mean I'm I know that there was
a there was a bill that was passed that
called for a SE separate bill that
called for a
study of um the appeals process in
environmental um uh matters um uh
representative
uh Vanessa uh what's it
um trying to
remember somebody make somebody refresh
my memory Vanessa
oh yeah please come on
up
okay so for the record my name is Rainey
peler I'm the Water Division director at
Dees and so as you might imagine a lot
of the appeals before the water and the
wetlands Council are basically looking
at areas of of housing Land Development
those types of things what I will say is
is that all of the appeals processes
whenever a permit is issued or denied it
is very clear on each of those documents
that in fact what the appropriate appeal
process is so let's say that we approved
the wetlands permit and and a butter had
some issues with that they within 30
days have their right to appeal and that
is clearly spelled out on that document
that comes out of our agency so once
that process goes forward it gets on a
schedule for the particular Council in
this case the wetlands Council and in
fact they will then go before a hearings
officer the appeals processes today are
overseen by the Department of Justice
and I think Alan Brooks is here he does
represent Dees generally so I I will say
that um the opinion would be that in
fact there is a clear path of how people
should move forward in the appeals
process I think when we're looking at
some of the issues of interjecting the
Superior Court versus the Supreme Court
years ago that was changed to Supreme
Court because people we found out that a
lot of people that were their project
was being appealed would basically get
worn down they didn't have the money to
deal with the appeal so they just walked
walked away so we found that that was
not fair that a lot of people that that
receed permits from us are just regular
General run-of-the-mill people in the
public that have a property they want to
do something with a lot of them don't
have the financial wherewithal to
continue to go through many iterative
processes for for the appeals hence it
was changed and went from the councils
to Supreme Court and so I guess legally
as far as any further questions I I'll
throw Allen under the
bus all right representative Smith thank
you Mr peler before you throw anyone
else under the bus I want to say that
you have been doing what you've what
you're doing for a very long time in
state government and one of the most
respected members of state government
you're involved now exclusively in terms
of water
can you tell me the name of the
overarching agency that you are now part
of thank you representative Smith I
think we've known each other for a long
time just for the record this is my 52
year uh with the department so I don't
know if that says that I'm not too
bright or not but at any rate when I
started out was the water supply and
Pollution Control Commission to speak to
you in 1987
that agency went away and it went to the
Department of Environmental Services
since 87 to the current time we have
been the Department of Environmental
Services when they created that agency
they brought together the wetlands board
and the Water Resources board as you
know representative Smith and other
facets so we went from the early days of
just water and wastewater to the whole
gamut of envir enironmental issues so I
oversee the Water Division which has
seven programs in it and I've been doing
that for a long long time so and and
doing that well what other
um operations for the I don't want to
use the word agencies because that means
something different what other
operations are going on in the
Department of Environmental
Services as far as programs
representative yeah yeah well in the
Water Division I'm responsible what
about other than the Water
Division pardon what about other than
the Water Division we have the waste
Division and the Resources Division okay
and in Resources Division what are the
areas well in the Water Resources well I
guess the point that I want to make
without dragging it out is that over the
year
as we have restructured the agency
additional um areas of concern have come
in under the aaces of the agency and my
understanding Mr pel here and you can
tell me if I'm wrong is that each of
those different
areas has its own procedures for
handling appeals and so the procedures
that you use which I'm sure are
carefully drawn and responsible may or
may not be the same procedures that are
used in other sections of the department
is that correct um respectfully I would
say that all three councils the water
Council the waste Council and the air
Council pretty much have administrative
rules that uh are the same thank
you representative Manos thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr peler for taking my
question um I'm wondering whether within
the process the council can consider new
scientific evidence or New Economic
evidence um and in the appet process
can um evidence of changing science or
changing economics come into it yeah
yeah and I I think I'm probably going to
defer the legal aspects of that but I
think when somebody files an appeal it
then goes before the council they get on
the agenda so each where the dees has a
representative there usually is somebody
Department of Justice and the attorney
for the appellant they in fact can come
in and if they have something new or
they have something that they want to
talk about that it's been pretty
liberal other question
comments thank you very much sir is is
there anyone else who wishes uh to be
heard on uh House Bill
1614 uh yes representative
staple sorry to belabor this but I'm
having trouble with this there was there
was a lot of stuff contained in this
bill and I just uncovered in one of my
notes um a letter from the Department of
Environmental Services
by um Robert Scott commissioner and I
just pulled out one particular paragraph
here nhdes is opposed to this bill
because it is inconsistent with other
provisions of law attempts to set the
review of Department decisions and rules
apart from the uniform processes and
standards applicable to all other their
state agencies and adjudicative bodies
and is likely to lead to significant
additional and unnecessary litigation
and Associated resource
impacts so my only upshot from that
would be to ask if uh the amendment and
the work session um U modified or
amended any of those concerns or
not you know I have to say I honestly as
I'm as I'm sitting here now I don't
remember I don't
my best recollection is if it made any
changes to those things that you're
talking about it wasn't it it wasn't a
lot that's my that's my recollection and
representative MC if I'm wrong on that I
think you wanted to me one of the things
that I
think I and I think Dees had a problem
with was the changing of the standard of
review to the sort of arbitrary and
capricious and I don't think that the
amendment changed that if am I wrong on
that um first I just want to say that
the whole purpose of this was to choose
Dees as a test let's see if we can
change the standard here arbitary and
capricious rather than just legal
because legal everything's legal for
Dees to do so it's impossible to
challenge that uh based on their
rulemaking Authority as long as what
they're doing is quote unquote legal
can't be challenged well that
fundamentally means that they're judge
jury and executioner they have all the
power and there's really no way to come
back later um the reason we chose just
Dees was because to promulgate this
across all of the different commissions
was going to be huge a huge Endeavor and
uh we know that there have been issues
with pasas right now that have required
more scientific evidence to be brought
up with a third party review preferably
the Judiciary of New Hampshire and
because the standard right now does not
include arbitrary and capricious it's
not possible to challenge that initial
evidence and so unfortunately we're in a
situation where our hands are tied
because we have given rule making
Authority without any other caveats to
Dees and now we as a legislature need to
look at potentially reigning that in and
saying okay is this about human health
can we find some other standard so we
could adjust the rulemaking authority
that is a totally different bill that we
could bring in to change it or we could
add this additional layer of judicial
review for arbitrary and capricious
standards so there are multiple ways to
attack this but in the work session uh
to answer that spe specific question
representative Stapleton asked um that's
why Dees was singled out because of the
timely concerns and because promulgating
this across all agencies was going to be
really complicated and then on the other
hand um in terms of the standard
arbitrary and capricious is what those
35 other states are using so we were
following suit with everybody else we
didn't change that um and I understand
the dees uh commissioner concerns
certainly they don't want to be singled
out uh but at this time we would need to
do some kind of a test balloon to see if
the legislature can allow these appeals
and then ideally promulgate that across
multiple agencies later once it works so
really yes Dees has the current and
present issue and so that was the reason
why is it singling out perhaps but it's
also timely um so happy to answer
further on that one but I think it's
just important to set the record clear
that there's sort of a history here as
to why it was done on the way it was
done um and and big picture I think
there's probably um some opportunity for
us to correct that and and make it right
as a
legislature other other
questions hang on one second so all
right thank you very much represent I'm
sorry someone else wanted to uh be oh
I'm sorry representative man thank you
Mr chair I just wanted to ask you um
representative MC Williams changing the
standard to arbitrary and precious
wouldn't in and of itself solve the
problem of the introduction of new
scientific or economic evidence is that
correct so the challenge that we've been
looking at right now is that an agency
makes a decision and then it goes to one
of these councils for for further review
and so whatever the agency has decided
whether it's arbitrary capricious or not
they've already done the scientific
level review so we heard in testimony
when we first brought forth this bill
months ago we heard from uh one of the
chairs of one of the councils that their
sole role is to review What was decided
by Dees and determine whether or not it
was in keeping with the statute so the
councils are reviewing statute they are
not reviewing scientific evidence and so
that gives us in the past scenario that
gives us no way to challenge inaccurate
science scientific analysis at the onset
by the agency and so that really is the
issue the arbitrary and capricious uh
standard gives an ability to take
another bite at the Apple later on in
the process when you realize wow this
was the wrong scientific analysis but
fundamentally the councils aren't
looking at that piece they're they're
defending the statute um and I do also
want to M mention um there's a similar
Bill uh House Bill 1622 that's very
similar to this one um in terms of
transparency and government uh
oversight um and we as a house passed it
by Voice vote um it is potentially up
for veto override so I just want to put
it on everybody's radar um this is about
refunding uh penalties when it turns out
that an agency issued a penalty
improperly against someone who was not
actually a bad actor and I do think that
again as legislators it is our role to
ensure fairness and Justice in this sort
of a situation so keep an eye on uh
House Bill 1622 when it comes up as well
thank
you anyone else
um thank you um Mr chair um thank you
for taking my further question just as
uh to put it into perspective that
letter that I quoted from was dated
February 13
2024 and the amendment
0926 was March 4
2024 um so did the amendment address a
number of issues in those letters to
satisfaction could you reflect on that
if that was so or not uh certainly we
looked at all of the letters when
putting together this amendment and I
feel that it was a balance of what is
possible and also the intent of the bill
again to give that true appeal
opportunity based on um the criteria we
discussed where there's a scientific
decision that was like Incorrect and
right now under the current process we
don't have a standard that allows that
appeal thank
you any other comments thank you very
much I think there's someone else who
wishes to be heard behind you come on
up my name's chip Kimble and I'm
chairman of the wetlands Council and
what I've just heard from representative
although it may seem I'm sure she
sincere is a
completely different from what I
understand um and what we're actually
doing um the misrepresentations seem to
be quite numerous first of all we do
hear new scientific evidence and that
does impact our decisions and it's clear
in the statutes which are is 210
uh and also in
04 and also in 21
M39 I believe it is which sets up the
hearing officer system there was a time
in years past quite a long time ago when
all we did was review the record of Dees
okay now we always have new information
because everyone is allowed all the
appellants are allowed to bring in new
information
the members of all the councils are
not employees of
Dees we are all separate individuals or
representatives of other state agencies
such as do or fishing game um state
parks different different agencies so we
are and we are separate agencies from
the es we do have the hearing at the's
office because that's the most sensible
place to have the hearings obviously our
staff which is our appeals staff our
appeals clerk is works at doj she's a
she's a member of doj the hearing
officers just recently we have made a
big Improvement in as of September the
beginning of September that we now have
a permanent hearing officer who is
primary whose primary responsibil ility
is the appeals
hearings can I just can I just ask is
that is that is that hearings
officer the the person that handles that
is the hearings officer for all of the
councils or just all of the all of the
councils same person right okay that
would be 21
M39 okay like that
um so that and and go back to the
arbitrary and capricious what what we're
charged with if you read I believe
that's
21 um
is unlawful and unreasonable
okay capricious is if you look at the
definition there if you go to blacks is
unreasonable and then if you look at
unreasonable it says capricious so the
difference between those two is
something that we could you know never
quite discern what what the difference
would
be the the bill as
proposed basically bifurcates two things
it
takes and sets a standard which roughly
the only difference is the addition of
change arbitrary and capricious and
apparently you know changes that for
some reason it also adds constitutional
if it's a violation of constitution well
if we ever declared it was a violation
of constitution it would go up to
Supreme Court I mean I can't imagine
that wouldn't make much sense and if
somebody but if you want to have us
decide whether it's unconstitutional we
could I suppose do that the other thing
that that section does is it revises how
we can assess whether Dees has followed
rules or not and instead it takes in set
a separate process up before the
Superior Court in marac County to assess
whether rules that have been set up by
dees are arbitrary capricious or simply
inconsistent with
statute whereas now we basically do that
so if we see that there's a rule that
had been in place and we determine that
it's inconsistent with statute which is
something that feels uh an appellant
would bring forward then we you know we
address that and say no you can't do
that because it's inconsistent with
stat similarly we might find that a rule
as applied in the particular instance is
unreasonable so I guess I'll stop there
for the moment there a lot of in a lot
of what appeared to me to be statements
that just don't quite understand what
the current system
is represent thank you thank you very
much um your comments have been very
helpful can you uh help me understand in
the comments you made the difference
between a
rule and a
decision Ru rules are established by the
department or by any agency we have our
own the councils have their own rules
that we establish for how to handle
appeals and how to handle the other
actions before us rules are established
by the agency to implement the
statutes and then in our case and and I
all all the council's case when Dees
proposes a rule if they propose it in
the wetlands area which is 482a or if
they report it say in a water Council
area which is other statutes or the air
area those rules go before that Council
and the council then reviews and can
comment on the rules okay and then Dees
has to take into consideration our
comments and then of course they go to
jail car eventually and are implemented
so when we have an appeal we're both
looking at the statutes and at the
rules to to determine if the actions of
Dees were consistent with those and
that's based on not just the information
that thees had at the time they made the
decision but it's based on that
information plus the information that
the appellant brings or interveners
bring before us at that time or Dees
brings before us at that time the new
information so the rules are not the
decision the decision
is what Dees decided in a
particular applic ation or a
particular say administrative order for
example in won's case someone builds a
structure out over the water without
Authority from Dees it's a violation of
a25 and you have to tear it down go to
482 a26 I
think so that's the decision that Dees
makes they tell those people oh you've
got to take that addition down then
those people appeal before us and we
look to see oh did they make that
decision properly did they obey all the
rules the appellant might bring forward
some you know exculpatory information
that they feel you know whatever but
that's kind of the difference the the
decision also would be a permit decision
so someone applies for a dock in our
case or applies to fill wetlands and
then someone complains and a butter
complains no you shouldn't do
that Dees un you didn't follow a certain
Rule and if they don't follow the rule
then we send it back we remand it to
them to correct
it thank you other questions
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I
wanted to ask you you testified when we
heard the bill initially correct yes and
I I believe you testified that your role
is to um protect the statute and not to
protect the environment is that what
your testimony was yes because we are
looking at the statutes and we're
looking at the rules we we don't have a
separate charge to decide that well the
statute isn't very good we ought to
change it for for example okay we had an
appeal somewhat
recently where it was evolved an
existing
Dam one of the things in fact the only
thing for the appellants that came up
was that it really would have been good
if Dees had reviewed fish populations
there wasn't in our opinion any legal or
rural requirement that they do that the
dam was already there and they were just
modifying the outlet okay so it might be
a great idea and we did say that's a
good idea you you need to change it or
you need to change the statute or need
to change a rule but we can't impose
our scientific knowledge if you will our
our
opinions over what the statutes or the
rules
say B may may I follow up yes no um the
statute says does it not that Dees shall
make rules in these areas is that
correct right and so that doesn't put
any constraints at all all on or very
little constra effectively no
constraints on the rules that Dees
promulgates is I would I would disagree
with that because the rules that they
promulgate have to be based on a statute
on the detailed statute if you're
talking about the simple purpose of say
a wetland statute or any of the other
statutes I I mean we're often a never
Neverland at that at that point um to me
but yes
um in the quest in the case that you
just described of the dam um you said
that that you're able to consider new
scientific evidence so I'm confused
about in the example you gave of for
example why there wasn't evidence about
fish populations there was a lot of
evidence about fish populations and
discussions about whether eels actually
made it up for example to this
particular location or what fish were
there there
and whether
Dees actually looked at the fish
issue
enough but that and that was there were
a lot of other things that were brought
up and that how this affected water
quality how it might affected someone
else's Wells how it
affected um the vegetation for example
that was that was growing there um and
that was evidence that had not come in
before Oh that right and proposals that
did not come in before right and the
other question I wanted to ask you is I
have a memory um I don't remember
whether it was you or somebody else who
testified about there being many
openings on these councils and that
their volunteer positions and that many
of them are open I think there was
somebody who was oriented around health
issues for example where that position
was open that's in the waste Council
think but there at this point fact we
were just going over but I don't know
how many openings we have left but in
the terms of the total councils I'm only
in charge of the wetlands but we have
one opening although I just found out
that we have one member who just
resigned so that would give two openings
out of 12 um the other councils uh
they've been doing a a good job trying
to improve that so they get you know
their their staffed up but we do have
anyway that's that's the openings and do
those openings affect your ability to
get um the perspective of experts in the
area um in our case no I don't know that
uh openings in the others I'm not sure
that they that they would I suppose if
you had a lot of openings so it might uh
but you have to remember that in in any
of these all of these councils all of
the members there are
scientific the vast majority of the
members there are scientifically
oriented or engineering oriented so for
them to accept and we're always
accepting testimony from various experts
the the case I happen to mention earlier
we had four different experts for the um
appellants maybe more maybe five
so I think many of us and in fact uh in
that case we had some serious problems
with some of the expert testimony and it
was easy for several of us to see that
for example in that case if you have
data for four locations or five six
locations excuse me and then you only
use it for part of those locations and
part of those dates that you've
manipulated your data whether or not
were
scientifically astute on the particular
data
but um and finally I wanted to ask about
um the the arbitrary and capricious
standard and I I just wanted to ask you
a little bit because you said there um
well uh 3 I think it was 34 other states
use the arbitrary and capricious
standard and I'm just curious um that
seems to be effective in other states
and I'm wondering what your hesitation
is about that
standard I'm not sure that it's any
difference you you don't gain anything
by by changing it except more litigation
over what happened when you change it to
me I mean it it I when that came B when
the bill came out I went to blacks and I
looked it up and I went back and forth
and then I went to multiple dictionaries
and went back and forth and you're just
chasing yourself around in a circle so
that's you know I don't I don't see the
gain
any other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir all right um
yes sure come on
up yeah yeah yeah now it's joh my name
is Alan Brooks uh I'm chief of the
Environmental Protection Bureau at the
Department of Justice I appear before
the councils next to me is Mark delforno
who represents the councils um we our
office does not take a position on
anything that you're going to do today I
thought it just might be helpful to
answer some of the questions that have
come up with respect to evidence uh all
of the hearings are now evidentiary
hearings 15 years ago that was not the
case there were record-based appeals um
and evidence is always admitted to give
you an example from the wetlands Council
just because the chair happens to be
here rule 20316 says evidence shall be
admitted unless excluded by the
presiding officer for being repetitious
irrelevant or highly privileged uh
legally privileged so it's common to get
new evidence uh I had a hearing before
the air Resources Council the issue was
whether or not
um eversource at the marac station had
been using what's called traditional
coal the agency had discretion to
determine what was traditional coal and
the issue was what the sulur content was
of coal the agency made its factual
determination it's scientific
determination about what the self for
content of traditional coal should be
PSNH at the time challenged that and
said it should be something different
and we had probably a two-day hearing
with experts on both sides saying what
it should be and the air Council
overturned the department decision
factually saying their decision was
unreasonable in that respect so evidence
is taken in we do hear from experts um
in that
regard the standard in
210 is that a decision of the agency can
be overturned if it's either
unreasonable or unlawful and that is
further Broken Out In 21m so that if
it's purely a legal issue if all people
are saying is it violates the statute or
rule on its face purely legal issue that
is a decision of the hearing officer if
it's a factual determination that
something is factually unreasonable the
decision is unreasonable based on the
facts that is the only decision that
goes to the members of the council so
it's like a judge and a jury if you're
familiar with that scheme so the judge
decides the legal issues the council
decides the factual issues but they do
decide those issues and they do overturn
the department if they think that it was
unreasonable the the standard for
unreasonableness is as far as I can tell
and the chair has stated exactly the
same as arbitrary and capricious in fact
one of the rule sets at least used to
say unreasonable means arbitrary and
compres so I don't think there is
actually a difference with respect to
that standard I'm certainly not opposed
to that standard I think that is the the
standard though that is used um and with
respect to the rules there are numerous
cases that have determined that Dees can
fill in the blanks all agents gencies
can fill in the blanks in the statute
and can add detail but they can't go
outside the parameters of what the
statute allows them to do so they can't
make any rule they can kind of fill in
the spaces in between so that's my
understanding in the process I don't
know if um attorney delforno has
anything he'd like to add I have nothing
to
add questions yes representative
come thank you Mr chairman uh you
mentioned 15 years uh ago you know that
the hearing uh I don't want to go 15
years but last few years are you having
more hearing than you know every year
you getting more and more
hearings I'd say I I don't know that
we've seen an uptick in the number of
hearings that's really unusual um some
councils get more hearings than others
the air Council gets very few the waste
division gets some the wetlands Council
gets a lot um and so with more
development you'll see more hearings
before the waste Council the other
councils I don't think I've seen any
increase followup Mr chairman yes so
uh you you said that you're not taking
any any any side you know you know but
do you think that system is
working well that's a great question and
I think that um we're always looking to
have uh the processes be better
especially again I appear before the
councils so if there's a frustration I
feel that frustration because I have to
either wait for a decision or I can't do
something I wanted to do so but is it
working the there were committees and
legislation um a few years ago to change
the way the councils worked in a pretty
substantial way to make it better the
problem has been since that
time that all right there's a new
system the hearing officer that was
there retired my understanding and
attorney delforno maybe can tell you
better that is the Department of Justice
had a lot of trouble finding a qualified
attorney to actually be a hearing
officer that slowed things down the
decision eventually was made to use a
number number of people in house to
handle the hearings but nobody had in
their you know job description the
ability to accept all of the council
work because there's so much of it so
one person would be assigned to one case
another person to another case another
person to another case and I think most
recently it was determined that that was
inefficient as well and so for the first
time just either a few weeks ago or
maybe a month ago one person at
department of justice has been
designated to be the hearing officer
along with that the longtime clerk Paula
Scott for the councils who brought a lot
of experience she went to Personnel
appeals board her supervisor Pam Monro
retired and the position was moved to
doj so there's no institutional
knowledge there that person has taken
some time to get up to speed so I think
that it is working but we won't know
until it's working until we now get the
next subset of information and we see
from this point forward okay everything
is now for the first time in place
should be functioning is it actually
going to work the way it's supposed to
work other questions representative
Smith thank you Mr chair um after a
decision is reached if the uh affected
party wants to appeal that decision to
whom is that appeal
made that's a good question so
Department the agency makes a decision
that appeal is to the council when the
council renders it decis its decision
that person can ask the council for
reconsideration if the Council made a
mistake or an error if that is denied
the person appeals directly to the
Supreme
Court and if I could follow up and
that's the same whether the appeal is
concerned with the law or with the facts
correct
thank you if I could ask one more
question
um I think you were very sensitive in in
talking about uh the problems that you
have with Staffing making sure that
people have the background and the
experience that that they need um as
these positions are moved from the
Department to
Environmental Services Department to
Justice
um is that likely to make it more or
less likely that um the people involved
will have the specific knowledge they
need I think that it will make it much
more likely that the people have the
legal expertise that they need and the
the factual expertise usually comes from
the council members who have been doing
that for a long time because those are
the factual issues so my hope is that
the expertise will be there it will move
forward I think it has gone slow over
the last year or since the change was
made um and again I appear before the
councils and so I express my frustration
to the councils when things don't move
forward and I've done that um several
times in motions saying can we move an
issue forward or can we dispose of an
issue thank you i' be permitted one more
question yeah thank you is there um
a backup at all in terms of pending
cases or are you able to follow the uh
the time limit
requirements there's no specific
requirement on when the council has to
hear a case but I would say that again
things have been going slowly for a
while because of the changes that I
described and I am definitely seeing an
uptick in activity in hearing officers
issuing decisions on motions to dismiss
summary judgment and setting hearing
dates within really the last two months
it's been very substantial increase in
moving cases forward that hadn't
happened in the months prior thank
you representative Manos thank you thank
you for taking my question um do you
practice before the four different
councils yes and are the processes uh
within the four different councils the P
processes
different they're essentially the same
so with respect to the information that
goes out to people on how to appeal I
actually can't remember if the permits
themselves put the information but a
Deni permit denial I believe has it and
I know that the administrative orders
all have it for all the programs so the
programs and I think I can't remember if
it was um you representative Smith who
asked about it the big divisions at dees
are air water and waste water goes to
two separate councils depending on your
issue either Wetlands or Water waste has
a Council air has a council and Dees has
what's called cross program rules for
all the councils and those are the
default rules each Council then has its
own set of rules that are a little bit
more specific but they're not you know
they don't change the cross program
rules they're not terribly detailed
they're not terribly long they add some
fine points to it but essentially the
process is the is very very similar if
not the
same
yes um the openings on the different
councils what what is your experience
with that and where are their openings
and do they tend to be
um what what representation tends to be
missing from from the
openings yes thank you for that question
it's an important
point when people are on a council and
I'm sure the chair can speak to this but
we're asking them to perform a very very
lengthy detailed task and not get
anything back for it so it's very hard
to find professionals who are willing to
take that much time and because they are
evidentiary hearings and not record
based
appeals most appeals will take more than
a day they'll take one or two days and
some of them take four or five and so
those people have to do that and I think
it's hard to find a professional who's
qualified who wants to set aside time to
do that it's even hard sometimes for the
agencies to appoint people who will
actually be able to um take people off
their job and come and do the very good
work that the councils do the important
work that the councils do but it's not
an easy lift for the people who were
there so where do there tend to be
openings and does it tend to be on the
on the consumer side or the health side
um could you talk a little bit about
that I don't have a list of current
openings right now so I'm I apologize I
wish that that I did know um and I don't
know if there's a pattern in that I've
seen it both from industry from private
um from the private sector and from the
state agencies all having problems
filling the positions at one point or
another sure thank you um it sounds like
to me based on your experience that this
is an area that um the legislature
should consider further um
you're intimately familiar with these
procedures and these processes and it
it's it's sounding to me from what
you're saying that this is an area that
we should really give further
consideration to and I'm wondering what
your thoughts on that are um and um yeah
i' I'd like to know your thoughts on
that uh again thank you for that
question um and again to be specific
Department of Justice does not take a
position on anything that you're going
to do my personal opinion is that I
think it's time to wait and see if the
now fully fledged process is going to
operate and I think that's what we're
all waiting for is to see okay now that
everything is in place is the relatively
new scheme that was adopted a few years
ago going to work
properly other questions for this
witness so I guess I I have two
questions the first question is before a
case gets to one of the
councils is there a hearing process
before Dees other words if somebody if I
want to put a you know I want to put a
uh uh dock on uh my property um uh and
somebody objects or Dees thinks that you
know I'm I haven't met the requirements
do I get a hearing before Dees or will
they just make a decision without a
hearing there is no hearing at the
agency sometimes they hold public
hearing ings on various permit requests
but there's no you don't as a permit
applicant let's say you don't get a
hearing before the agency but it's not a
cold process there are pre-application
meetings you can have meetings during
the application process you can have
exchanges of information and the idea of
that is so that you don't waste time on
an appeal when something could have been
resolved at the agency so those
processes are there there's one
additional process related to permits
not administrative orders which is the
statute allows a preliminary notice of
appeal so without filing a full-fledged
notice saying here are all the issues
I'm appealing you can file a preliminary
notice and say Here's what I'm looking
at can we enter into settlement
discussions with the agency and the
agency's then put on notice they'll
review it and decide whether or not they
want to have settlement discussions on
there before it ever gets to it even a
preh Heering conference second question
I have is if the legislature were
inclined to
create something akin to the housing
appeals board but for envir all
environmental appeals other words to
sort of um replace the councils and I
don't mean replace them in terms of all
they do because I understand they do a
lot of things other than deciding
appeals but if the legislature were to
decide in terms of the
Appellate role of the councils we're
going to take that away from them and
create a
new you know environmental appeals board
um with three members or five members or
what whatever would there be enough
work in the whole environmental appeals
process from all the you know what are
now the four councils to to to keep that
board you know busy on a full-time
basis I'd have to go back and look at
the numbers my guess is that it's a
full-time job if you did all four
environmental council did all of the
appeals that that will be a full-time
whether you're the hearing officer or a
member that will be a full-time job okay
and do you have any view on that I mean
suppose that the legislature we say
we're creating the environmental appeals
board it'll have three members one will
be a lawyer one will be an
environmental engineer and I don't know
one will be a you know or maybe one will
be a you know an environmental engineer
coming from industry and another will be
an environmental engineer coming from
the environmental movement or something
like that what would your view be on
that it's a policy decision I think the
councils were broken up in the way that
they are because they repeatedly see
issues that are very distinct from each
other and have very different technical
background so Wetlands will hear you'll
have people on the board who uh used to
be dock installers let's say and people
on the board who are into conservation
and wetlands conservation you know to be
the other side fish and game will sit on
those because they might have a wildlife
you know interest and what's going on
very different from let's say the air
Resources Council where you're talking
about uh air emissions from Power
people with the background in chemistry
are probably needed for that people who
understand the very complicated um
because we implement the um Federal
program Clean Air Act Title Five permits
and the very complicated air issues same
with the waste division now we have an
overlay of cira and Superfund and
different issues that are associated
with uh with that so it's a policy
decision whether the legislature thinks
it can train one board to do all those
but I think the policy decision was made
years ago to say let's let people focus
so that we can choose people with
expertise in those very specific Fields
all right thank you other
questions yes represent Wallace thank
you um you've talked about these uh
different uh commissions within Dees but
one that hasn't been mentioned and is uh
involved in almost every permitting
application is the uh Heritage and
cultural commission who handles appeals
of of that to that
board thank you that's a good question
it's the Heritage Bureau is not housed
within Dees as far as I know they're a
separate um they're separate in a
separate agency they may be in dncr
you're in dncr okay so they're in dncr
right now the Department of Natural and
cultural
resources and um it's a requirement for
many of these that you ask the Heritage
Bureau okay is there a hit for for a
species or or something in there but DS
doesn't control that and if they make a
decision one way or
another it's not um I don't know of what
the appeal process is for the Heritage
Bureau or if there is or if one exists I
I really don't know it's a good question
and just to so people understand what
happens is as an applicant you ask the
Heritage Bureau you get a letter back
that says yes there is a hit or no there
isn't a hit and that's I think the
decision that you're talking about right
correct and I do not know what the
appeal process would be for that well
it's been my experience every time I've
gone for any type of a Shoreland
application or anything like that every
single time you have to get that uh dncr
go or noo fortunately they've all been
in my favor but I can imagine that that
would be a very difficult hurdle to
overcome should you uh encounter one of
those would you agree with
that yeah I mean to some extent um I
suppose you could raise the issues at
the council in the context of the permit
that you've applied
for and I would have to check with
Heritage about how they do it I don't
know if there's some discretion that
they use or they just maintain the
public database that says here's where
we know threatened and dangerous PES are
or are not your property is one where
there's a hit on the list or it's not a
hit on the list so I'm not sure there's
other than reading the database I'm not
sure they do much more than that but
again I don't know what the appeal would
be from that decision thank you I just
wanted to ask that because that's
absolutely part of the application
process and if we're trying to address
the appell process um it needs to be
considered yes for wetland and shorland
that is part of that process I'm not
sure it is for um some of the other
programs thank you other questions
all right see done thank you very much
um so I guess um I'm not sure if you
made uh yes okay so we have uh a motion
to recommend for further legislative
action um move by representative Smith
second by representative Wallace any
further
discussion
um yes representative
trip uh I know previously had uh uh made
recommendations for uh further action is
there a difference between further
action and different further
consideration represent Smith I'm gonna
ask you our options are recommend or not
recommend oh that's it yeah okay oh no
no recommendation right no recation
thank you all right so um anybody else
have any comments so I guess what I
would say is I you know I think it it
seems to me clear that this ought to be
the subject of some further um
legislative consideration exactly what
that should be whether you know whether
I mean it might be it seems to me it
might be to do exactly what the last
witness just suggested is they have a
new system in place let's let that
circulate see how it works that might be
what a future legislature decides or
they might decide to have some kind of a
establish some kind of a new board um or
um they might want to fool around with
the standard of review although I have
to say as reason I stepped away from the
desk for a minute I I went you know I
went back to the standard of review it
seems to me whether it's in
21 uh the 21 section for the Department
of for the environmental Bureau or the
the the basic overall standard of appeal
that applies in the Supreme Court it
seems to me that U Mr Kimble really is
correct I the wording may be it doesn't
use the words arbitrary and capricious
but it seems to me the standard that
applies uh is um uh whether or not the
decision is not only unlawful but
whether it's
unreasonable um and
uh or or I'm sorry I should say unjust
or unreasonable and seems to me that um
it it although the it really is a kind
of a semantic difference because if
something is um of uh clearly
unreasonable or unjust um it's probably
arbitrary and capricious that's another
way of uh phrasing it um and so I don't
know that that makes any difference but
at any rate that's again may be
something to be looked that in a future
uh at a future
time I have very good news for you Mr
chairman all we have to do is
say yes it divert you know further or no
further and it is the next legislature
that then has to worry about it so some
of us may be in the next legislature
some of us won't be
but we don't have to worry about a thing
now oh that's exactly right all right
any further comments representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair
um boy there's a lot of spaghetti
there's a lot of sauce on this spaghetti
and uh I I just the words that it's been
working better in the last couple of
months um and like to see where it's
going to
go implying that there's Improvement in
the works
um it ain't perfect but it ain't broke
do we really want to fix it and that's
not our job as representative Smith
points out so I'm I'm kind of like want
to back off of this and do a non-
reccommend um and let's let the people
who deal with this stuff on a daily
basis bring forth their news as well as
their concerns and recommendations uh to
the Future
legislature okay are
other
comments all right um I I appreciate
what you say representative Stapleton I
I guess I think that um my sense is that
there's uh you know that there's enough
here that we would want at least to look
at it further I mean it may it may be as
I say I a future legislature might well
decide well maybe we're not going to do
it next year we'll wait a couple of
years or whatever but I I I would say
that you know it would be appropriate
for a future legisl to at least um
consider that that matter so I would say
you know I would be in favor of of
recommending further further
action all right um I guess anybody else
have anything to say yes representative
Khan one last thing Mr chairman because
I was not in a public hearing on this is
my first day of this subject so anybody
can tell me that when this kind of
subject was reviewed by the legislator
you know the last
time when was this was reviewed or you
know any legisl was done last time to
further improve the uh Apple
system you know I don't have an exact
date but my understanding was it wasn't
all that long ago that the system that
was described by the two witnesses from
doj it wasn't all that long ago that
that system was implemented I'm I don't
remember when that legislation was but
maybe do you have a can you tell me when
that
happened okay all right thank you
representative Wallace thank you and I
might just point out for everybody
present that the dees is now going
through the required statutorily that is
desial rewrite of all their
administrative rules is that not correct
Mr pela
correct
correct and it shouldn't be after the
recent Chevron deference
decision all right representative stap
just for clarification the motion is to
recommend further legislative
consideration or action
further consideration consideration
further legis I could go with
consideration but not action okay all
right I'll word it that
way consideration all right so I we
ready for uh uh vote on this yes we are
okay it was uh no no decision that's
those the things it doesn't matter about
us want right it was recom it was to it
was representative Smith moved that we
recommend further uh legislative
consideration and representative Wallace
seconded so um the vote will be on that
motion all right call the rooll vice
chair Wallace votes yes representative
Khan yes representative
Andress representative testman yes
representative Stapleton yes
representative trip yes representative
Dolan yes representative Boyd yes
representative Smith representative
Horgan yes representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Kenny is not voting
representative Paige is not voting
representative Divine yes representative
lonza yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Ming yes chairman Lynn yes okay 161
motion carries thank you all right all
right um I will uh write the
reports which will be very brief on all
three of these and I will circulate it
to uh to everybody um probably by the
end of the day uh
um um and I guess with that um I think
we are done until veto day uh right uh
so again I hope uh let's hope that this
weather continues and I hope everybody
enjoys the next uh time between now and
Ando okay thank you very much thanks and
thank and thank you to our substitutes
for for for being here could I see shell
and Zoe just for a
second hey you
you for